[Music]
it happens every year but it's taken on
added significance because of the war in
ukraine a parade to commemorate the
soviet victory against nazi germany 77
years ago
an estimated 27 million soldiers and
civilians from the soviet union died in
the second world war russian president
vladimir putin compared the previous
fight against fascism to the invasion of
ukraine
you're fighting for our people in
donbass for the safety of our motherland
russia may the 9th 1945 will forever be
perpetuated as a triumph of our one
single soviet people of its cohesion and
spiritual might and perilous exploits
both at the front line and at the home
front
[Music]
military hardware was on display as the
parade made its way from red square
through the streets of moscow
it's designed to send a message but at a
time when russian forces are struggling
to gain the upper hand in ukraine it's
also a show of force for national
consumption
this war appeared to be much more
difficult and bloody than uh we expected
we expected that uh this will be
battle for dunbas will continue
probably to the until the
middle of
summer and then uh based on the result
of this battle on the bus
new political decisions
will be made
with few outright victories in ukraine
some russians had feared putin would use
this occasion to announce national
mobilization and formally declare war
against ukraine that didn't happen
instead putin said russia must ensure
there is never another world war
ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
had a defiant message for moscow
on february 24 russia launched an
offensive step
the same mistake has been made by every
occupier who's come to our land
we have survived various wars and
they've all had one ending our land was
planted with bullets and shells but no
enemy was able to take root here
this is a day that unites most russians
in remembrance and national pride but
ukrainian and western leaders say
russia's invasion of ukraine is
repeating the horrors of the past
victoria gatenbee al jazeera
and we have a team of correspondents
across the parade and the developments
in the ukraine war in ukraine assad bake
is near slovyansk and hoda abdulhamid is
in kiev but first let's head to
dorsojabari who's in the russian capital
moscow hello there dorset just how
different is this year's parade in light
of that military operation in ukraine
well the first thing that was noticeable
was the speech by the russian president
vladimir putin within a minute of that
speech he started talking about his
reasons as to why he decided to send in
those russian troops into ukraine he
said that um he was uh forced to it was
a preemptive rebuff to aggression he
accused nato and the united states of uh
planning to
attack
crimea which russia annexed in 2014. so
he really spent most of the time when he
was addressing the crowd to talk about
the so-called special military operation
that russia is carrying out in ukraine
and vladimir putin
said it was
important that the
people of russia understand that this
was done for the security of the country
he also thanked the military men who
came to this parade in red square he
said some of them came directly from the
battlefield in donbass what was also
different this year was that there were
no foreign leaders present during this
event usually there's a
number of foreign dignitaries that are
invited to attend this parade but this
year none were invited and no none were
in attendance there was also supposed to
be a number of um air shows that would
be taking place over the skies of red
square but according to officials from
the kremlin citing weather conditions
they've all been canceled there was
supposed to be 77 aircrafts to signal
the anniversary that is the 77th
anniversary of the
victory day here in russia but that's
been cancelled so there was just this
different sense this year but certainly
vladimir putin's very much in command of
his decisions reiterating uh to the
russian public that his decisions to go
into ukraine is just and that they will
be victorious yet again
and also how is the rest of the day
going to unfold to mark this occasion
well we solve vladimir putin after his
speech walking over to
the alexander garden in the kremlin
laying flowers over there are 12 blocks
representing the 12 what are known as 12
hero cities
and of course two of them are
marked with kiev and odessa those are
the cities that were part of the soviet
union they were awarded these honorary
titles as hero cities for
displaying exceptional heroism during
world war ii and the irony was not lost
on many people saying that as the
fighting continues in odessa
vladimir putin is laying flowers on that
block commemorating that city but
following that the um there is a march
that is due to take place in the coming
hours that is called the immortal
regiment march and vladimir putin has
also taken part in that in the past
because this is when people ordinary
people take photographs of the members
of their family who they have lost
during what they call the great
patriotic war here in russia and they
march towards the kremlin area of the
city here and they really commemorate
what they lost and the family members
that they lost during this war to
remember those that have fallen
it's a very
long and emotional journey that they
make towards the center of moscow and
it's also
carried out throughout all the other
cities across russia we also saw that a
number of events taking place not only
in russia but also in mariopol as well
as crimea we saw a parade happening in
sevastopol and also in mariopol there
was events held to commemorate this day
all right thank you for breaking it all
down for us dawson jabari live for us in
moscow let's head to ukraine now where
uh hoda abdul hamid is in kiev hoda
despite the victory parade in moscow
there's obviously still a war going on
where you are what's the toll so far for
both countries
well indeed there's a war going on and
president zielenski a short while ago
gave another of his video statements
he's so famous for uh while he sort of
mirrored what uh president vladimir
putin said by reminding everybody that
ukraine is fighting for its own freedom
he also underlined the fact that
ukrainians uh paid a very heavy toll in
world war ii and continue to pay that
very heavy toll
during
this war
for both sides it's unknown it's it's
been very costly
russia has lost an enormous amount of
soldiers we don't know exactly the
number the ukrainians say it's about 25
000.
russia puts that number between 13 to
1500 only uh the battles are ongoing on
a daily basis ukrainian cities are being
targeted even in the west where
infrastructure is being uh pummeled and
then the outcome of all of this with
vladimir putin saying that he's coming
here to protect the ethnic russians the
russian speakers well the outcome of all
of that is wherever there is a battle
wherever the russians uh
sort of focus their firepower well there
is total destruction and alienation of
the same people uh vladimir putin has
been saying that he wants uh to protect
many people i met over the past three
months told me how they were not going
to speak russian anymore and they were
sort of fast-tracking to learn ukrainian
uh because they said if they if they
were two-minded before this war well now
it really cemented their ukrainian
identity but this is a war where
ukrainians are also paying a heavy toll
there's more than uh 3 000 civilian
debts so far uh children women there's
12 million displaced so certainly a very
high cost for no victory on the ground
so far and and hoda there are areas
under russian control at the moment talk
us through that briefly
well there is the herzone region which
is south of uh
ukraine um that is now fully under
control of the russians actually it
was the first regional capital to uh
fall under
russian control at the beginning of
the war um so now
russia actually today carried out small
parades little concerts and villages and
towns across that region we saw some
picture of that on
on social media but by and large we were
there just a few days ago the people of
her son have fled and when we talked to
them
many
described a very dire situation uh
saying that there was nothing was
functioning anymore there was no
pharmacies no banks that people were
bartering i remember one man telling me
that he was exchanging eggs for uh
cheese and so forth so certainly
and we asked them who stayed behind well
they said that russia was uh
bringing people from the crimean
peninsula so certainly maybe an effort
to put some show a victory there
uh but the people of that region are not
there to assist to it all right thank
you very much hoda abdul hamid live for
us in kiev let's head to the east of
ukraine now where assad bake is standing
by news of yanks assad what's happening
on the ground where you are
well in the in just in the last arrow so
we're not far from mikhail
and we've heard and seen that getting
hit by the russians now we heard the
incoming and then we saw the smoke
rising behind us just in the last hour
now elsewhere in the east the russians
continue to try and
take territory
and the aim as they've stated is to take
the east and the south and essentially
landlocked ukraine elsewhere we know
that the russians have paraded in mario
pole even though ukrainian forces still
remain at that metal works plant and
what we've heard from the authorities
here in the donetsk region is that 15
locations were targeted the russians
have used airstrikes missiles heavy
artillery
as well as tank fire now we've just gone
through the town of cremators now that
had a population of around two hundred
thousand it's down to around forty
thousand now what's very striking is
when you go to places like this it's a
bit of a ghost town what strikes you is
the silence you tend to hear the birds
singing and the dogs barking
occasionally disturbed by the sound of
artillery fire and just to give you an
example of something that we saw today
was we saw a little girl out in the
street holding the hand of her mother
and just for a second the few people
that were there just stopped and stared
because that's not a sight that you
often see in many of these towns and
cities
that are in the firing line of the
russian forces so it is the ukrainian
people that are facing the brunt of this
war there's queues at petrol stations
there's limits on how much fuel people
can buy but the fighting still continues
across
across the east as russian forces
continue to try and take more territory
all right thank you very much for that
update assad beg new slavyansk for us
let's get some further analysis now with
teresa fallon who's the director of the
center for russia europe asia studies in
brussels she joins us by skype from the
belgian capital theresa thanks for being
on this newshour as we heard from our
correspondents there was a lot of
commentary in the lead-up to putin's
speech that it could be used to
officially declare war but while it was
a defiant speech he made no major
announcements how do you interpret that
i think it's very significant many
russian analysts said that we shouldn't
put so much emphasis on the may 9th
victory day celebration in moscow and so
the high expectation that there would
that putin would need to refurbish all
of the soldiers by having declaring war
he could actually
have
national mobilization of the population
and
draft more soldiers but in the speech he
did note that donbass is russian
territory so you cannot declare war on
your own territory so the narrative
coming out of moscow is that this is
russian territory and there are other
ways to get more soldiers i mean i when
i lived in moscow sometimes people would
just be rounded up at the metro station
uh in a very ad hoc fashion so there's
no need really to declare war on this
and my take was that it was very somber
uh event it was very uh putin actually
moved very smoothly he walked you know
with uh
with
you know he had no mistakes really he
didn't there was no shaking of his hand
so i'm sure everyone's watching very
closely as well how he delivered his
speech and that if there were any
tremors or any sort of health issues
actually he looked pretty good today
teresa he's also continued to use
rhetoric around ukraine's defenders
being nazis while evoking russia's
victorious world war ii past has putin
successfully fused those narratives and
how would that be
received by russians
well that's what he was trying to do
with his whole presentation and speech
today trying to use the the russian
nostalgia for the soviet past i mean 27
million russians died and that wasn't
even revealed to the soviet public until
uh gorbachev came to power and that was
part of you know the idea of opening up
and letting people know before that it
was like a state secret because they
thought too many
the population would be too saddened to
know 27 million russians had died so
they really do feel uh i should say
soviet citizens died because a lot of
the fighting and dying happened in the
area that is ukraine so the ukrainian
there is having a parallel narrative
going on which i think zelinski was very
wise to do he did an interesting video
black and white it looks something like
world war ii and that the real nazis
here in this narrative are the russians
that's how the ukrainians are spitting
it so we have a battle of narratives
going on here and if people are
skeptical of this narrative in russia uh
well we've seen four million people
leave russia some of the best and the
brightest so some people aren't buying
it the rest kind of might want to
believe this because
if you grew up in the soviet union
ukraine was always part of it and they
might feel comfortable with this
narrative but the younger people might
not be buying into it as much
and how would his speech be received
abroad particularly by the likes of
germany and the rest of europe
this is really irritating many germans
because it's constantly this
nazification campaign so it is kind of
an irritant in the relationship and
we're seeing german leaders kind of
calling out putin because this is very
sensitive issue and let's remember
germany is kind of dragging their heels
a bit on russian energy sanctions so
maybe
this narrative is a bit of a clash
russia wants continued support from
germany german businesses to
kind of help water down or delay any
sort of energy sanctions it looks like
though this will be a long term event
putin didn't try to make it sound like
there was great victories it was very
somber and in fact you didn't even hear
him talk about the special military
campaign he didn't use operation uh and
we didn't so there are certain things
that were interesting that did not show
up that language wasn't used and he also
called up you know did a call out to all
the
nurses and doctors that are helping
injured russian soldiers so i thought
that was an interesting nod
acknowledging that there are many people
who have been injured in this war as
more and more bodies come home but this
might
water down support for this
activity in ukraine well we appreciate
your analysis as always theresa fallon
director of the center for russia europe
asia studies in brussels thanks for your
time on this newshour
thank you